hey
welcome back to the monitor peter rubin
senior editor
at wired and this week we got a lot to
talk about on screens tv shows tv movies
moving picture shows let's start on the
small screen to talk about the return
of nbc's community finally
for a select few viewers they do not
enjoy the highest ratings
community is one of the smartest
funniest sitcoms on television and while
it is not yet
to its six seasons and a movie hashtag
battle cry
four season is starting up this week nbc
delayed it from its original october
start from this season and they pushed
it to february
that's all right they pushed it from
thursdays to friday nights that's all
right
we don't cur we're just going to dvr it
anyway screw you nbc
at any rate the weird thing about
community is dan harmon
the creator and showrunner is gone nbc
sacked him last year so a lot of people
were wondering
me included what was going to happen to
the show also leaving were two of the
executive producers
who helped give the show its character
however i am pleased to announce that
at least with the first episode of the
new season community is about as
community-ish as it's ever been
which is to say weird which is to say if
you've never seen community before and
you watch this episode you will be
wondering what all the fuss is about
but it is it is it is really
quintessentially community they do some
structural satirical things they have a
lot of
their characters doing very
characteristic things i can't say too
much because the show hasn't aired yet
and uh nbc has warned those of us who
have seen the episodes not to
give away certain points from the
episodes so i will just say that
everything that started
happening last year is still happening
yes troy and brita are still together
uh yes abed is dealing with the fallout
from that yes they are back for their
senior year and we're going to see what
happens at any
rate that is thursday no that is not
thursday nights anymore that is friday
night's
community on nbc let's talk about tv
movies
tv movies do you love battlestar
galactica i love battlestar galactica we
all love battlestar galactica that's
probably why you're watching a podcast
that wired makes
at any rate battlestar galactica awesome
the prequel show caprica maybe not as
awesome but now
battlestar galactica blood and chrome
which is another kind of in-between
prequely thing
airs sunday night as a two-hour tv movie
now
blend chrome aired in small installments
late last year on machinima which is
a youtube multi-channel platform
as they are known uh blood and chrome
follows a
young bill adama after he gets out of
the academy when he becomes a
viper pilot it is uh well it was a ten
part thing and now it is a two hour
thing so it takes place
after i believe the original 70s show
but
well before the uh the events of
the new battlestar galactica that we all
know and love from sci-fi
uh in the past few years that is sunday
night i actually did not watch it in
installments on machinima because i knew
it was coming and i wanted to wait
uh some of the writers who were involved
with the show are holding out hope that
scifi still might take these to
take the show to series so if people
watch it in enough numbers let's hoping
we can
convince them to do that and get some
more bsg back on the air that is sunday
night on sci-fi network
battlestar galactica blood and chrome
let's talk about a real big screen movie
okay so so steven soderbergh has been on
uh
he's been on a tear at least a a tear of
productivity
in the past few years he has put out a
kind of astonishing number of movies
uh considering how hard it is to make a
movie
and it's been not the most even
i mean he i i love him as uh as a writer
and director and i think he is a
fantastic filmmaker
but i have to admit to being a wee bit
disappointed by both
haywire and magic mike however
he's brought back together kind of uh
his some of his favorite performers for
a movie that starts this weekend called
side effects uh
catherine's eddie jones who obviously
was in traffic and the informant which i
love channing tatum who was in haywire
and who's in magic mike
a host of other people it is essentially
a psychological thriller
that uses the pharmaceutical industry as
its backdrop and as some say mcguffin it
is
soderbergh's last movie he claims before
he goes away for a little while
i don't really know what he's going to
be up to but it sounds like this is your
last chance to get your uh your
soderberg fixed before an extended
filmmaking hiatus i'm sure he's got
other irons in the fire
but for now if you respect the man's
craft
you owe it to yourself to check it out
this weekend that is side effects
from stephen soderbergh also written by
scott z burns who wrote
contagion another cyderburg movie and
the aforementioned informant which is
one of my favorite dark horse soderbergh
movies
so that is this weekend and also that is
it for the monitor we're going to be
back next week
with an all-new batch of pop culture
deliciousness but until then
inspirational catchphrase here